lara trump is an animal rescue advocate
and strongly pro dog she joins us
tonight laura thank you so much for
coming i can't think of a story there's
something so grotesque about this and
just absolutely awful but i'll stop and
let you
assess what you think of it
yeah i mean it's it's so tragic
on every front really tucker this entire
situation it used to be that we had a
few spaces left in our society that were
not tarnished by politics and obviously
animals was one of those spaces and
unfortunately as you just heard there
thanks to a shelter and no surprise
california that apparently is gone as
well and and here are the numbers
because it's roughly six million animals
a year that find themselves sadly in
shelters
they all are looking for homes and
unfortunately just shy of about a
million of those animals are euthanized
every year because they can't find homes
and obviously we know the shelters are
overrun so what you have here is a
situation where a group that claims to
care about animals is telling us very
happily that they care more about
discriminating against people for
constitutional rights for their second
amendment freedoms than they do about
finding good homes for animals and the
two are not mutually exclusive it's not
that you can be a responsible legal gun
owner or be a loving pet parent because
you're looking at a great example of
that i happen to be a strong supporter
of the second amendment along with my
husband eric we have two dogs that
believe me take up more space in our bed
at night than even the two of us they're
living a great life
but the saddest part of this is all of
those animals that of course are not
going to find a home now because of of
people's just complete ignorance and
total intolerance it is so sad to see
and quite frankly a really awful
commentary on our society as a whole at
this point i think well it's just so
unbelievably cruel and by the way the
people i know
who love and understand their dogs best
hunt with their dogs i mean
that's right
and i appreciate you coming on tonight
laura trump and for all you do on behalf
of dogs thank you
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight